somebody sent me a piece there's a group
called Media Matters which is
a you know it's a censorship
organization funded by Soros and a lot
of other people who hate Western
Civilization designed to prohibit people
from saying certain things well the
things that they're prohibiting people
from saying are 100% true and that's why
they're prohibiting
it somebody sent me a piece today where
Media Matters attacked a guy for
suggesting that our historical timelines
were wrong and there had in fact been
Advanced civilizations in early moments
in time and that they had been
eliminated somehow through climactic
events through natural disasters and
that were not aware of them in any
detail I that's really interesting
hypothesis I have no idea if it's true
it kind of seems to be
true I'm not emotional about it either
way I don't you know I'd like to learn
more because I think it's really
interesting we have no idea how the how
the pyramids were built for example how
could we not know that we sent a man to
the moon and you can't replicate the
technology that created the pyramids you
can't even you don't even have good
guess as to how they were built
we don't we don't even know when they
were built that's those are facts so a
normal curious person would say well why
don't we know that and what does it tell
us about ourselves and about the past
that we don't know that's what I would
think people would ask they were
attacking this guy for asking that
question and I was like why would Media
Matters care about your opinions on the
pyramids why do they care or whether
they were big civilizations in Illinois
10,000 years ago which there were by the
way that used metal
amazing but why would anyone care well
they care because that's true that is
just true and the current version of
history that we've been told is not only
incomplete it's just wrong it's just
flat out wrong now I don't know what the
truth is I don't know what it means I
would never claim to but I know that
what I learned as a kid is wrong and so
it is much closer to the truth to say we
have no freaking idea how they built the
pyramids and that's kind of amazing and
Media Matters was offended now why were
they offended they were offended purely
because it was true